[Música]
vai ser meu prazer hoje conversar com
vocês sobre a universidade é situada nem
a prática de projeto para transformação
o que eu quero dizer com isso parte da
minha própria experiência pessoal como
professora aqui da universidade né é não
todos nós sabemos que a universidade é
composta por um corpo de disciplinas né
todo aluno passa por essas disciplinas
ea minha questão foi como que a gente
pode pensar e repensar essas disciplinas
na ótica de um processo transformador né
é e aí eu vou partir da minha própria
disciplina né que é o design é que é uma
disciplina de projecto
nós sabemos que existem três disciplinas
de projeto nem as mais famosas e
conhecidas na engenharia arquitetura ou
design e eu eo meu ponto de vista que
nessa apresentação mais especificamente
sobre uma delas e das experiências que a
gente tem tido nela é enquanto prática
transformadora e repensando a própria
disciplina é eu não estou sozinha nessa
né
existe uma rede internacional né de
escolas de design que estão trilhando
esse mesmo caminho né
mais de 50 escolas é quase 50 mais 50
escolas pelo mundo estão sempre entrando
né é e que se chama uma rede de vezes
nem são escolas que estão repensando
também essa mesma disciplina então é um
exemplo de como toda uma rede de escolas
pode estar reunida nesse mesmo esforço e
aí eu queria fazer uma pequena reflexão
mais filosófica mais aberta mais
conceitual sobre o que é a prática do
projeto né
é o projeto enquanto desejo intenção de
fazer realizar algo no futuro ele tem
esse aspecto de plano né é preciso uma
série de competências para chegar ao
resultado esperado em que figurar
configurar esse resultado esperado e tem
que planejar como que eu vou chegar
nesse resultado esperado mas o projeto
e é muito interessante ele tem também
essa dimensão de você se atirar me
projetei né eu me projetei no caso
arremessar se lançar se e que seria
pensar uma universidade que se projeta
né que projeta como o ato de projeto e
também se projeta nem é preciso futuro
desejado e nós sabemos que temos uma
série de desafios né
é interno na universidade mas também na
nossa sociedade em sustentabilidade
ambiental né
as práticas de consumo que são cada vez
mais insustentáveis em um ciclo infinito
obsolescência planejada de produtos e
crise da democracia enfim muitas muitas
muitas dimensões problemáticas que nós
vivemos
e aí pareceu me que uma das grandes
questões seria isso né como eu poderia
então responder nem como professora que
ensina uma disciplina dentro de uma
universidade a esses desafios e sendo
uma disciplina projetual e aí uma
questão que surge é como a gente pensa
uma disciplina no caso meu caso design
para além do mercado nem o que é o papel
da universidade né que quer ser educado
nem o ser treinado o ter base ter
fundamento né que seria o design ele
nasceu com 1 teve muitas referências à
revolução industrial não necessariamente
nasceu mas com o processo de produção e
consumo que hoje em dia foi conhecido
como extremamente sustentável então
repensar de uma disciplina passa a ser
uma coisa muito muito importante nesse
processo de mudança e eu chamei né e se
essa que eu vou explicar como é que isso
acontece e já tive um projeto ao fazer
um ativismo uma transformação que parte
do reconhecimento da prática de projeto
que o ativismo disciplinar e que eu
estou dizendo aqui é que nós podemos
pensar todas as disciplinas eu tô
trazendo pra vocês a experiência do
design né
quando a gente pensa em design a gente
pensa logo em consumo de moda né e
várias outras coisas relacionadas mas
não a gente pelo bom como é que a gente
pode então nesse contexto que a gente
está vivendo
é repensar uma disciplina e torná la
ativa esse ativismo como ativa nesse
processo de mudança né é e aí como eu tô
dizendo e aí tá em cristo nisso o
projetar o ativismo ea prática de
projeto pode ser ligada a várias
disciplinas e eu comentei com uma colega
minha que inclusive a professora que o
futebol é muito ativa em movimentos
sociais eu falei assim fimca é vamos
como é que a gente pode achar uma
solução como é que a gente pode projetar
esse problema que você está
reivindicando e ela comentou comigo
seguinte olha não é meu papel propor no
meu papel projetar no meu papel
desenvolveu uma solução
eu quero eu vou protestar eu vou
reivindicar
eu vou pedir tá então eu perguntei mas
como não me conhece mais esse problema
como você não mas eu e meu papel e pediu
alguém vai projetar alguém vai
solucionar tá então ela se retirou dessa
questão positiva e aí a gente pode ver
também muitas muitas pessoas que
analisam e teorizam sobre questões fazem
uma análise muito profunda das questões
sociais envolvidas dos processos de
exclusão dos processos problemáticos que
ocorre em práticas de projeto feitas por
outros que a gente diz nossa claro hoje
pessoa estão sendo preenchidas por esse
projeto
as pessoas estão sendo oprimidos por
essa iniciativa
mas eu pergunto a sua análise é
fantástica quanto à sua proposta
silêncio
então eu falo sempre gente quem projeto
propõe e desenvolve uma solução se
lançou propôs e ro acerta erra construiu
propôs fez então se você tem uma análise
uma crítica porque você não pode repor e
propor uma solução né
é isso significa desmistificar um pouco
apático projeto claro que o projeto são
feitos por profissionais mas existe a
possibilidade de uma atitude de projeto
de fusão ou seja nós podemos propor
soluções nós podemos fazer e além de
dentro da universidade pode ser
extremamente transformador porque nós
temos instrumentos de análise potentes
para entender o problema fundo e para
consequentemente fazer uma proposta
ninguém conhece mais problema do que
você e aí só trazendo um exemplo pra
vocês
o quanto isso é importante na prática de
design trata se só o desenvolvimento de
soluções né eu resolvo isso eu acho isso
aquilo tentativa e erro né gambiarra mas
eu estou construindo eu estou propondo
uma ideia mais visualização o que você
tem na sua cabeça
eu cheguei para o aluno perguntei o
aluno chegou pra mim ainda numa prática
de produto muito especializado e
perguntei pra ele confessou eu quero
fazer uma saboneteira foi legal desenha
para mim é saboneteira ele não sabia
desenhar então não tinha acesso a idéia
que ele tinha na sua cabeça
então é muito importante que além da
gente ter as idéias ea gente desenvolver
soluções a gente possa estar lá e fazer
com que as pessoas possam entender a
nossa ideia e isso gera um processo de
aprendizagem social de conversa sobre
possíveis soluções de vídeo e eu quero
isso quero aquilo de bola aqui porque
nós não podemos fazer assim mesmo mas
olha só isso aqui não está muito bom por
isso por aquilo para o piloto é uma
discussão baseada em propostas concretas
tá isso e aí outro pilar do que eu acho
importante que eu tô querendo fazer para
vocês hoje é um exercício do espelho né
como que a gente pode virar essa prática
do projeto para nós mesmos porque
geralmente não têm
vamos projetar para os outros mesma
disciplina de projecto tradicionais
então eu vou lavar projetar porque
aquelas pessoas têm o problema
aquelas outras pessoas estão com
problema como é que eu posso
como é que a gente pode projetar para
nós mesmos para os nossos contextos de
vida onde eu moro no meu bairro no meu
condomínio
na minha no meu ônibus onde um passo de
trânsito onde eu vivo a minha vida
cotidiana
o que eu não posso projetar para onde eu
vivo né
e como é que eu não posso na
universidade isso como uma tática de
ativismo crítica e transformadora né e
sobre o nosso próprio contexto em
projetar para o outro ninguém conhece
mais o meu contexto do que eu mesmo e aí
que a gente chama de uma prática situada
nós somos os mosquitos
eu sou situada no contexto de vida e eu
estou tentando fazer hoje aqui na
universidade como professor é o meu
contexto de vida atual né é projetar
para nós mesmos
e aí a partir de ser mudança e essa
mudança se projetar sobre a cidade sobre
o brasil e projetar a nós mesmos fazendo
aquilo acontecer
tá eu tenho aqui uns exemplos que eu vou
passar rapidamente de artes práticas de
preto e vejo um projeto à universidade
na própria ufrj esse é um projeto que
foi desenvolvido pelos alunos da da
universidade porque é uma perda de
pressão vão conhecer a ufrj eles ouviram
uma série de histórias de professores
antigos técnicos administrativos antigos
falam nossa que coisa fantástica eu
nunca tinha ouvido falar dessas
histórias a gente passa pela
universidade não conhece nada disso ele
desenvolver um projecto memórias da
merda né 15 na nossa universidade que
por uma série de eventos e dispositivos
as memórias da universidade ficariam
registradas e nós poderíamos ter acesso
fomentando o nosso nosso sentido de
comunidade aqui na universidade né
além da universidade alguns alunos nos
próprios no próprio condomínio porque
nós nós temos alguns já casos disso mas
eles na época achar
isso é um caso muito interessante como é
que nós podemos compartilhar uma série
de ferramentas que nós temos nossos
próprios apartamentos de uma maneira
comum como é que nós poderíamos aprender
a construir coisas em comum
até dentro da própria cultura maker
nessa um condomínio em copacabana
o terceiro caso foi um workshop que eu
acabei de dar no méxico mas poderia ser
muito bem no rio de janeiro o conceito
de cidade partida né que é o conceito do
gene ventura que a nossa cidade é
dividida em várias áreas que não
conversam uma com a outra
câmeras proteções não pode ali vamos
ficar aqui fechados né
ele identificou esse mesmo problema na
cidade do méxico
e aí a gente achou bem para animar
paradigmático de uma situação de várias
capitais latino-americanas que é o
seguinte as pessoas às ruas dava pra
essa rua pq era uma antigamente as
pessoas foram fechando as ruas laterais
e criar um corredor mistério que ninguém
passa com as grades de um lado e do
outro e ele achou aquilo incrível no
próprio bairro que ele disse foi um dia
tem corredor é que parte do bairro no
meio eu não ia ali ninguém transita né
e aí ele pensou que ele poderia fazer
uma série de atividades culturais nesse
corredor ativando a rede de escolas
locais inclusive escola efe próprio
filho dele estudava como é que poderia
se ativar esse lugar e você já observam
que eu chamei de preto civismo
todos os processos são assim a gente tem
que partir de algum lugar é eles fizeram
essas idéias e aí com sempre na
universidade porque muitas vezes o
estudante de graduação e os estudantes
não acredita no seu poder de
transformação
mas foi só uma ideia que eu fiz o curso
bota na gaveta
eu tive um aluno que anos depois pelo
professor esse prêmio e aquele meu
projeto que eu fiz há 45 anos atrás de
um prémio de empreendedorismo sei aonde
ele acreditou na sua capacidade de
transformação seu contexto de vida tá
a gente precisa acreditar mais nem o
aluno na graduação na transformação no
potencial que vocês têm de ter soluções
e idéias então dentro dessa idéia eu
estou explorando tentando com você
explorar é tentar fazer uma prática
infra estrutural ou seja que vocês os
alunos que trabalham no mesmo bairro
partilham as histórias com os alunos que
vieram do período anterior criando uma
massa crítica em cada bairro da cidade
pode ser que não dê em nada que os
alunos continuam acreditando que eles
podem mudar onde eles vivem continua e
continuando a sua a sua sensação de
impotência ou pode ser que de repente
nesse ciclo infraestrutural os alunos
começa a acreditar coxa nós podemos
fazer alguma coisa juntos no nosso
bairro
no nosso local nosso condomínio então
essa prática espiritual contínua no
contexto de vida de vocês tá onde o calo
aperta onde a dificuldade tem mas não só
pensando em problemas
a gente tem que pensar também
oportunidade né pessoal porque tem muita
coisa boa que a gente pode conectar e
fazer florescer né então não só
problemas e aí eu chego na questão do
nosso teto x como reconstruir a
universidade eu já dei várias dicas até
agora né do que eu estou pensando e como
eu tô pensando porque isso pessoal como
professora eu tô na parceria
estou fazendo isso porque eu tô nesse
contexto de vida né e eu e os alunos
eles estão vindo os contextos de vida
com os sonhos com as idéias né e eu tô e
uma das coisas que eu percebi é que a
gente pode construir uma nova
universidade o novo professor e um novo
aluno é um exercício para um novo novo
tudo nesse processo é que a gente pode
fazer essa parceria
que obviamente nesse processo vocês vão
ter uma outra visão também da sua
prática a nec dizer como é que eu como
qualquer disciplina dessa universidade
posso ser esse elemento de transformação
como eu posso ser propositivo ativo não
somente analítico é como é que eu posso
propor sínteses exemplos que possam ser
base para discussão e sem medo mas essa
minha idéia tão pueril não ninguém
conhece como eu repito ninguém conhece
mais o seu contexto de vida do que você
mesmo então nenhuma das suas ideias
é pueril e outra uma prática de que o
projeto projetar com outros
e pra chegar essas soluções tá é isso
gera uma relação entre a universidade ea
sociedade como um todo diferente também
vejam bem é vocês são agentes de mudança
que estão aí na cidade estão aí no mundo
e vocês se reúnem aqui como um grande
laboratório
vocês estão representando diversas áreas
da cidade diversos contextos
socioeconômicos
você chegou no meu curso falou gente
vocês são vocês podem gerar cenários
quem o rio de janeiro está reunido
pensão da cidade seja uma das que se
projeta no seu contexto de vida do seu
bairro na cidade do rio de janeiro está
fomentando laboratório de transformação
tão poderoso como esse jovens estudantes
passaram por mil filtros educacionais se
sentaram ali eu digo vamos pensar novos
cenários para a vida cotidiana na cidade
do rio de janeiro conhecer as
oportunidades que a gente tem quando
onde a gente tem esse fórum pessoal na
cidade
quem está se reunindo para pensar a
cidade como mentes jovens e bem
pensantes quanto vocês são uma outra
visão uma outra relação com a
universidade e também não só e não
desprestigiando nós precisamos ter
situações de assistência mas também de
transformação contextual e situada né
é uma outra questão que eu queria
compartilhar com vocês é o seguinte eu
como professora
vou ficar aqui muitos anos eu sou um
ponto fixo no fluxo certo eu tô aqui
vocês vão passar cinco anos vão embora
quatro anos oito anos né cada um tem a
sua trajetória mas eu sou um ponto fixo
no fluxo
o que significa isso pessoal eu aprendo
com cada um dos meus alunos porque se eu
aceito que vocês são representantes dos
contextos de vida de vocês e que vocês
chegaram aqui trazendo essas realidades
eu tô aprendendo com vocês vocês passam
e eu aprendi quando vem um novo grupo e
restituam então como eu posso me
entreguei integrar profundamente nesse
fluxo e ser parceiro de vocês nessa
transformação é a minha proposta também
como professora que nós juntos possamos
transformar o contexto e eu falo do rio
de janeiro que nossa querida cidade onde
a gente está situado
mas como vocês podem ser agentes de
mudança do futuro onde quer que vocês
estejam no bairro do condomínio na
cidade na casa da família na das
organizações que vocês vão trabalhar
muito obrigada pela atenção um prazer
[Música]